Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 27th,
2014 and a fuck you,
we'll put a,
I'm actually recording this thing late.
I'm recording it late and then I got to go to work.
I gotta go to work or Billy Day job.
Oh Billy Day job.
But oh Billy burning in a pole fence.
You know,
something's got to give.
Why does it always have to be out?
He you put your work first.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I don't know what the fuck that was.
I am sitting here as you can tell by the echo,
echo,
echo.
Maybe you can't hear it,
but I can hear it.
I'm sitting in my living room because I'm doing this Monday morning,
eight 30 my time.
So this is still a Monday morning podcast where I'm from despite all use selfish
Douche bags around the globe,
around the planet,
you know,
and people took that thing and the nose on this beautiful bill blue sphere that
we called mother earth.
I just,
well lets me know when somebody's going to lie to you.
They start shaking their head when they're given the stage.
I want to thank everybody for gathering here today.
Wow.
High got Italia.
That you know what we got coming in.
I often they start shaking their fucking head,
you know,
trying to charisma their way through fucking stealing all the tax dollars.
Um,
anyways,
I didn't do,
I didn't do shit this weekend.
I didn't do any standup did I?
No,
I didn't.
I just fucking stayed in trying to catch up on my goddamn sleep here.
But I've been doing stand up during the week and I got a big standup gig coming
up.
I'm doing a the 20th,
um,
annual,
uh,
comics come home benefit for our cam Neely,
the Cam Nealy House,
uh,
put together by Denis leary and the always adorable Jimmy Serpico.
Oh,
he's adorable.
I challenge you to find a picture of Jim Serpico where he doesn't look
absolutely adorable.
That is an adorable middle aged man.
Um,
I got that coming up,
so I got to make sure I'm on my game because I'm going to be following a bunch
of monsters.
I think I'm going on the last,
you know,
and that is the deal on those things.
You don't headline one of those,
you go on last because you're going on after all headliners.
So,
um,
it's not a lot of meat left on the bone,
if you know what I mean.
I can't really see myself 10 comics in being able to bring up a bowler and it's
still a fresh topic,
if you know what I mean.
Right.
That's why I'm doing a bit on the mumps.
Yeah,
the forgotten one,
dude.
I gotta be honest with you.
I am so fucking sick of all these diseases.
Grand standing during sports in every fucking police should go like it's,
it's all this,
this got their marketing diseases now because they're trying to get your money
for research somewhere in there.
I know there's a good thought,
like they're trying to cure the disease,
but there's a lot of Lexuses.
Lexis is,
this is is being bought off of that money.
You can't tell me that there isn't because I don't give a fuck how much you give
a shit about stopping the disease at some point.
You want a nice house and you want a nice car and if all you do is try to find a
cure for that fucking thing at some point
been to the Aspirin Fund,
right?
Jesus fucking Christ.
The combination of this and the and the and the,
the the fucking getting reprimanded.
When you watch a football game,
no more,
no more go fuck yourself.
I'm not hitting anybody the fuck off my TV.
You fucking dope.
What do you think that some wife beater at home who's going to see the
commercial and then be like,
oh,
okay,
you just going to erase 20 years of bad parenting with some dumb fucking
commercial with your black shirts on.
It drives me up the fucking wall.
You talking to me like I'm two years old and you're also talking about this,
this major fucking problem as if it's like,
you know,
why don't you just fucking hire one of those planes with the banner across it
and just tell society how the fuck this supposed to behave?
I'm sure that'll solve something to add and know.
Just fucking drives me nuts.
The whole fucking thing drives me up the fucking wall.
Stand for cancer and everybody's standing up with a name of somebody that they
had.
All right.
Who doesn't want to stop cancer?
Who doesn't give to it?
Do you got to interrupt a fucking the world series to remind me that there's
people dying of cancer?
Sports is supposed to be my safe haven.
Maybe my Golick was right.
I mean,
it's my Mike Golic.
That's my Mike Gull Lake.
That guy is a stammering jackass.
You know?
You know you're dumb when you have to constantly bring up the smart school.
You went to
fucking dust.
I know what you can a lot of you guys to think of right now.
Bill,
have you been smoking along to cigars lately?
Is that what it's for?
The uh,
the cough.
I have not.
All right.
Oh,
freckles here actually went.
I've gone eight days without a cigar and now it's out of my system.
I don't crave it right now.
I let the humidor dwindled down.
Is that the right word?
Human door?
Yeah.
I say humidifies via voice.
Human doors for cigars and humidity is that thing that people who don't
understand weather get mad at.
When somebody says it's,
it's not the heat,
it's the humidity,
and then they go out.
That's like Shane,
he's not the bullet.
It's the gun.
No,
it is.
It's no,
it isn't.
If you fucking read up on humidity,
you dumb fuck.
If you got out of the East Coast and down south and you headed out west and you
felt a dry heat versus that ungodly fucking moisture
that is in the air when you have,
you know,
basically what happens is,
is when you have hot air,
that's what,
that's what's known as a low pressure system
and the molecules get larger.
Really doesn't.
All it does is there's just really no moisture.
You know,
like if you live near a fucking desert,
it doesn't make a difference how fucking hard it is.
There's no fucking moisture due to extrapolate,
you know,
and bring to that fucking hair is essentially what's going on.
Okay.
That's why it's awesome to fucking live out here.
Now I don't understand.
We live near a fucking ocean.
I don't understand how some of that water doesn't get in the air,
but God knows it doesn't.
It does not.
We live right now in the Mojave desert.
I don't know what it is.
No,
Santa Ana winds comes down to the fucking canyon.
I think it just drives everything the fuck out like a giant hair dryer.
So when you out here and it's 90 degrees,
I mean it feels more like when you walk to your car that God has a microscope,
none of microscope of fucking magnifying glass right on the top of your skull.
Right.
As opposed to when you're back east.
I'm still,
it's like one party.
Your body's just like,
oh my God,
I got to get in the fucking car.
As opposed to when you're back east.
We just walking out with the arms to the straight out,
like he got something like your nailed to some invisible cross just walking down
the street.
You just can't escape it.
You take a shower and two seconds later you're all fucking soaking wet again,
Bill.
We understand it all right.
I didn't even explain it well,
but I'm a moron anyways.
Um,
okay,
and comment.
You hit it.
Jesus Christ,
a fucking plane.
His clothes,
he's fucking people out here are,
are lunatics the way they fly this fucking people in helicopters and airplanes,
they fly like 800 feet above the fucking ground.
It's just like,
where are you going to put that thing if God forbid you had a fucking engine
failure?
Huh?
You're going to try and land here with all the fucking why is um,
all right,
I'm all over the place.
Yeah.
I need to focus here.
Um,
anyways,
I ended up big sit down with my,
uh,
okay.
My contractors and all that type of shit and we're finally,
uh,
on our way here.
We're on our way.
We're finally getting to the final.
Uh,
I'd say 20% of the job.
That's how fucked up my downstairs was slash all the other bullshit that happens
when you're building something.
Um,
you know,
you know what kills me is right up the street.
Some lady bought a house and gutted the whole fucking thing and she has workers
over there seven days a damn week.
However,
I know what they're doing over there.
They're flipping a fucking house.
I'm not flipping a house.
I'm having a hundred percent quality.
You should see,
you should see the fucking plumbing I got in down there.
All copper piping us just fine.
It's gorgeous.
It's almost,
it's almost a fucking shame that they're going to close up the walls.
That's how fucking beautiful the work is.
That's been done downstairs and this house used to basically be a house on top
and a tree fort down below.
It is now an absolute fucking fortress and some day when I go to sell this
thing,
I can,
I can look the person in the eye that I'm going to sell this to as opposed to
the fucking,
I don't even know that I've,
I honestly think that people who lived here before,
I just,
I don't think people even understand some of them.
Some of them are actually out the fuck he over.
Okay.
Like whoever put that fucking tarpon downstairs to hold back four feet of dirt
army,
four feet high level of fucking dark.
Okay.
Maybe three feet.
I don't fucking know.
All I know now is I got a concrete barrier going all the way around like I'm
supposed to,
everything's up to code.
Okay.
Item master electrician come in and rewire the whole fucking place.
I got copper pipe and going through all the guy,
we chased the pipe all the way up as far as we could go.
You know,
there's a few galvanized pipes,
sections of it here or there,
but generally speaking,
um,
you know,
if this house is going to be a,
it's going to be rock solid and Ivan Shelly
so fucking depressed with how long that this shit has been taking that.
Um,
I,
last night I actually went on the,
uh,
the Internet and I was looking at other houses like,
fuck this,
I'm out.
You know,
you know,
like when you were in a relationship with someone that you just love.
Okay.
So you can't break up with them.
But every once in a while you just start thinking,
you know what?
If I just went out and I bought a fucking corvette,
you know,
and I just got a scarf or some shit and just started driving around and just
live for me.
I started doing that with my house last night and I just looked at all the other
houses and it's just like I can see it.
I can see it in all the houses I like.
I like old houses and every one of them now,
I don't see the beautiful house with all the character anymore.
You know what I see?
I see wood rot.
I see cloth wiring,
I see galvanized pipe.
I see a gas leak,
you know?
That's,
that's all I see.
I see a fucking new roof.
I see flashing that wasn't put in properly.
I see all of that.
That's all I see now.
It's all I see.
I see the cracks,
you know on the walls.
Okay.
No one that you know,
I see windows that aren't going to close fucking properly.
That's what I would do.
Now when I walked in to a house,
if I looked at a house now,
I would start opening,
closing windows.
I checked the water pressure,
I'd go under the house,
you know,
smell for gas and all of that type of shit.
Now you know something.
As much as I did all of that,
I'd still get fucked because you can't stick your head in a wall and you have no
idea what the fuck's in there.
You've got no idea.
You've got no fucking idea.
How many times over the course of the life of that house,
some fucking vomit or some goddamn road and got into the fucking wall,
chewed on what left?
A bunch of fucking shit pellets.
I'm telling you,
okay,
it's horrific.
The only thing you can do is maybe,
uh,
a brand new house,
a house that was,
uh,
just bought in case you don't know what brand new means.
And then even then,
I don't know,
something's gonna fucking happen,
you know,
I dunno,
I'm soured on the whole fucking thing.
And I put my God damn life savings into downstairs and I don't think I'm ever
leaving.
That's it.
I'm fucking done.
All I need is a friend with the pool and I'm good.
It's fucking dust that put in the floors and downstairs,
which is fucking exciting and dusty all at the same time.
So anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
My name is William Burke being very official this week.
And uh,
yeah,
I didn't do shit this week.
Um,
oh,
for those of you,
for those of you who are on the Internet this week,
and you might've saw a,
we finally announced the show that I've been telling you that I've been writing
on.
Um,
I actually sold an animated show to Netflix.
A cartoon is,
I like to call them.
Everybody calls it,
it's an animated show.
It's animation.
It's a cartoon.
I sold a cartoon to Netflix.
They greenlit six episodes.
So this is a real thing.
This is coming out.
It's coming out.
Um,
uh,
the name of the show's calledF is for family and it's about a family in 1974.
All right.
It's basically,
I'm animating my childhood stories.
The people that I kind of grew up with a nobody's,
um,
in particular,
just sort of the way shit was back then.
And uh,
I'm working with a bunch of great people who all kind of grew up in that era
too.
We all kind of had the same moms and dads and friends and neighbors and all that
type of shit.
So,
uh,
it's not going to lie to you.
It's the most work I've ever done in this business.
But also what has been the most fun of anything that I've ever done.
And I can't wait for you guys to see it unfortunately because it is animation.
It's not going to be out until a year from December,
which coincidentally enough I think is when they're going to finish the bottom
of my house.
So it's all gonna come together for me next year,
next year in 2015 December.
Yeah.
Come Santa Claus.
Here comes Santa Claus right down Santa Claus Lane.
Billy's bass man is fucking fanish and he's got a show.
Please fucking watch it.
So I make money,
dope up,
a doable do pool.
And then I'll have to buy a roof.
All right.
Um,
so that's coming out.
Yeah.
Are you a year from this?
December is when it's coming out.
I Dunno why they announce it as soon as they do,
but,
uh,
we got a great cast.
We got Laura dern is going to play.
My wife Justin Long is playing.
My son,
uh,
David Kempner is playing my boss and uh,
they're all absolutely fucking hilarious and we got a bunch of other people,
um,
doing voices on there.
And uh,
like I said,
it's the most fun I've,
I've,
other than doing stand up,
it's the most fun I had.
I can't wait for you guys to see it cause I think it's going to be pretty
fucking,
it's pretty over the top.
Put it that way.
Um,
and I know what you think and what bill,
how did you come up with an idea like that?
Well,
you know what,
I used to tell my childhood stories on stage and only twisted people would laugh
and the rest of the crowd be like,
so I was walking my dog one day trying to think how to fucking,
I do these things where people will,
uh,
you know,
fucking loosen up a little bit.
And I was like,
all right,
I'll animate it.
I'll do a cartoon.
Those aren't real people.
They have three fucking fingers on each hand and then nobody can get mad and
nobody can get offended.
And that's been the most fun about doing this as we've been writing this thing.
At no point have I got one network note saying,
wow,
what is it?
What are we promoting drug use that's violence against women.
This is,
you know what,
what's Peter going to say?
Nothing.
Cause it's,
it's cartoon people doesn't fucking count.
Um,
so there you go.
So I've got that coming out.
I know it's a long ways off,
but I'm excited about it.
So I'll be talking to you.
Uh,
we've recorded,
uh,
you know,
some episodes at this point,
we're about halfway done.
And,
um,
I can't,
I,
you know,
I just been having the time of my life,
don't when it,
so that's what I've been doing.
All right.
And with that,
let me read a little bit of advertising here.
Let's pay for the fucking basements here.
Um,
all right.
Sorry guys.
The fucking throat.
I know.
It's annoying.
All right.
Draft kings,
everybody.
Let's listen.
Is Our winning huge cast prizes,
cash prizes every week@draftkings.com America's favorite one week fantasy
football site one week fantasy means no season long commitments play whenever
you want.
Got An injured player,
not a problem at draftkings where it's like a new season every week so you're
never stuck with the same players.
Rex Ryan out of play this,
Huh?
Poor bastard.
Uh,
pick your team in minutes and you could be on your way to winning instant cash.
Last year,
one player turned 11 bucks into four grand.
Another one a hundred grand his first time ever play.
And another one a million bucks in one day.
Just playing fantasy football.
Hurry and get free hurry and get free entry into the $100,000 fantasy football
contest this weekend where first place takes home 10 grand.
Call to action.
Head over to draft kings now and enter the Promo code deep fence to play for
three draft kings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings.
Big a million into defense for free entry now.
Now that draft kings not calm draft kings.com that man right there.
draftkings.com
dollar shave club,
everybody,
guys,
dollar Shave club.com I've been talking about them for years.
They deliver great raises for a few bucks a month.
If you're not a member,
what's your hold up?
What are you waiting for?
What do you old ladies,
you want to go down to the CVS and stand behind him?
Huh?
Smelling that creeping death or do you want fresh racist delivered to your door
every week?
Once a month?
Look,
Vic,
they'll have a bunch of fees.
Hit you with a bunch of fees.
That's what's worrying you.
Don't worry.
Dollar Shave club.com has no fees.
You just pay for raises the razors that they ship you and that's it.
Get there.
Four blade razor and for replacement blades sent to your door each month for six
bucks,
including shipping.
You don't want to get locked into a monthly commitment.
We understand dollar shave club.com doesn't have any contracts.
It's all under the table Doe.
And if you decide you don't want raises for a month or two,
they won't send any and you don't pay a dime.
They're basically running their business the way they should be.
Don't know if you'll like their products.
I already told you their stuff is amazing,
but if you don't,
if you don't agree,
dollar Shave club.com we'll refund your money.
No questions asked.
MMM,
stop with the excuses.
Unless you're some idiot who likes wasting money?
Go sign up@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar uh,
right now I'm telling you what's great.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar where was that when I was a child,
not a child,
when I was first starting to f to shave.
You know how much money I've fucking blown on razors.
I don't,
I don't even want to know.
you want to know it's too scary.
All right.
Ah.
Boda Boda
alright.
NFL football.
Talk to all the ladies.
Just,
you know,
walk away from the podcast this point.
All right.
Go make some Goddamn Pumpkin Pie.
You know,
go put on an apron and some horse shoes and walk around the kitchen like you
used to when relationships worked.
Okay.
Before you were bitching,
moaning and complaining at me during the football,
both from the kitchen and on my television set.
Oh,
Jesus.
Bill,
What's wrong with you?
All right,
let's talk about,
um,
let's talk about my New England patriots.
Huh?
How'd you like that?
CHICAGO?
Huh?
That was for Super Bowl 20.
I hate when people do that when they think that you can get revenge for a
playoff game.
Play offs,
a play off game during the regular season.
Um,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say,
uh,
that was just a bad game for Chicago.
I'm not saying they would have won the game,
but come on.
That was fucking ridiculous.
The the end,
the final like five minutes of the second quarter,
they should have been no announcers.
They should have just been playing Benny Hill music.
Anytime the fucking bears had the ball.
Where am I going to Africa,
Daniel.
They are.
You know,
we score 21 points in like four and a half minutes was,
I didn't even,
I didn't even watch the second half.
Put it that way.
Put up a 50 spot on him.
Five zero.
And you know what?
As much as I want to rub it in their face,
who beat who in the Stanley Cup finals?
Who beat who in the Super Bowl?
Exactly.
There you go.
Okay,
there you go.
So no Chicago fan should feel sad.
There's not one Chicago fan out there that should feel sad.
You guys have had a lot of success.
You had Michael Jordan,
right?
85 bears.
The bears is a little rough,
you know,
but you got the Black Hawks.
I'm making up for it.
And now you cub fans.
I don't have that.
You guys do.
You don't even care.
You started Karen,
when some fucking nerd wearing a Walkman touched a foul ball and you all piled
on him like fucked up fucking pussies.
You are Chicago cub fans.
What about the other six guys standing around also reached up for the ball.
What's a matter with a out of your weight class?
You wanted that guy with his little hat pulled down over his head.
You fucking punk.
I don't have any sympathy for Chicago cubs fan because they don't even give a
fuck.
They've only given a fuck for like the last 10 years.
But other than that,
it's just been take your shirt off and let's have a keg party.
Nobody cares.
You're on there.
Almost like an honorary baseball team.
Like,
yeah.
You know,
just this represent the fact that people like
the game,
you know the white sox fans,
they care.
They give a fuck.
It's written all over their guide.
Damn faces.
You know,
they still miss their old ballpark.
They hate that new place.
You see them coming in with their heads down,
go and look at his stupid ass fucking thing.
You know,
we had a classic fucking car and we traded it in on a Ford Taurus.
What the fuck did we do?
You know,
see can feel for those guys.
They give a fuck.
Chicago cub fans do not give a shit.
All right?
So if you're a tourist,
if you ever go to Chicago,
okay,
and you run into somebody,
you know,
and I got a passion for what they're doing.
That's a white sox fan.
If you run into just some fucking jerk off,
you know,
sitting there wearing loafers with no socks,
in some silly fucking let's play two hat that is a cubs fan and they are not to
be respected.
See what I did that people,
not only did we just beat them,
I just cause hopefully some arguments right now between people in Chicago.
That right there was a terrorist act right here on the podcast and you listen to
it because you didn't do anything because you didn't hit stop.
You actually became a part of it and now you're liable.
What do you think about that?
All right.
Um,
actually,
you know,
as well as the Patriots are playing and they look great.
How the fuck are we number one in pass defense?
I had no idea.
I've been watching every game.
Um,
I would say,
and then we're like last in the run or some bullshit like that.
So I,
I actually think this next week when we play the Broncos,
you know,
if we win,
um,
decisively,
then I'll actually believe in this team as far
as their ability to possibly,
uh,
you know,
go deep into the playoffs and maybe make a run at this thing.
But I gotta be honest with you,
who the fuck is good this year in the NFL?
Who is like,
like without a doubt.
Fucking good.
Like,
look at the fucking Seahawks.
I don't know what the hell happened to them.
They won't like four games this year.
I don't even,
I made gains were into two at this fucking point.
What are you eight weeks in?
We try to pull this shit up here.
The standings [inaudible] now.
Um,
but that would have thought the Steelers we're going to,
we're going to lose,
do,
fuck would they play in?
I don't even remember.
I'm the horse.
What do I do?
This shit.
What the fuck are the Seahawks?
Seattle Seahawks are four and three.
You're telling me the Arizona cardinals six and one,
like as a patriots fan,
I got to sit there and think if we make it to the Superbowl,
Holy Shit.
We might play the car knows,
look out for those lions.
I,
I'm not even buying the eagles.
I don't believe in that coach or the quarterback.
I don't think.
I don't know that anybody's good.
The giants are three and four.
I Dunno who little radius.
Oh,
and seven Broncos is six and one.
I think he could actually,
uh,
I dunno.
I think we wouldn't,
we would have a tough time,
obviously with the Broncos who'd have a tough time with the colts.
I don't get the bangles.
I don't get them.
Everybody was talking about how they were fucking unbelievable.
And then they came in to Foxborough and get the living shit kicked out of him.
It's Cincinnati.
They're never going to win anything.
These,
you're going to just look a uniform.
You just like that.
You get done.
You're never going to win a Superbowl.
This Cincinnati Bangles,
it's fucking over.
They look like they're,
you remember that?
That Broadway show cats?
That's what they,
if you put a helmet's on those fucking dancers to dream the impossible dream,
you know they could do that.
Why am I being a Dick?
You know what?
Cause I gotta I gotta fucking blow to this podcast and I gotta go to work and
I'm fucking,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm not in day job shape.
I haven't had a day job since 1995 and I got to get up every morning,
pack a fucking lunch,
like a jerk off.
I'm just fucking with you guys with all your teams.
Um,
I actually feel,
feel really bad for the Raiders,
man.
Oh,
it's seven.
What the fuck?
I watched a little bit of that game yesterday.
How about that Brown's defense?
Huh?
Their offense sucks.
One guy goes down on the old line and all of a sudden everybody rolls over.
The fucking pocket's collapsing.
11.
They're going.
I know it was a major injury.
Really.
So then everybody sucks on the offensive line.
I don't understand that,
but their defense look phenomenal.
But granted they were playing their age.
Um,
all right,
let me just get,
let me bail out of this.
I obviously don't know shit about football this year despite the fact I've
watched almost every week.
Oh I see.
Movement.
Is that the lovely Nia?
They'll lovely Nia
dirt.
That egg.
What's gone?
I just get the wave.
She's come in in.
Um,
anyways.
Oh you know what I did yesterday?
I was all over the last two days.
Cause it's a,
it's Halloween.
You know me,
I get up for the holidays.
I think it's very important to us start traditions around the holidays.
You know what I mean?
It reminds you of your childhood.
You create new memories.
Right.
So I made six loaves of Pumpkin bread.
I've been handing them out to my friends like a fucking drug dealer,
you know,
cause they're wrapped in foil.
It just feels like you've got a brick,
a weed,
you know,
riding around in my fucking,
I'm riding around in a Prius
with one of those,
uh,
save the earth grocery bags,
the cloth ones filled with pumpkin bread,
dropping it off to friends.
Okay.
If you can be any more feminine and still be straight,
if you can top that,
I want to know what it is.
That's your homework this week.
I want you guys to send me an emails that you,
you feel that there's something beyond driving a Prius with a cloth grocery reg
filled up with pumpkin bread that you made,
dropping it off to France.
And I want you to find something that's more feminine than that as a straight
guy.
And don't just tag on to what I just said and add like skipping.
You know what?
I'm going to fucking just go hack up whatever the fuck is in my mind.
Hang on a second.
Hang on.
Well,
let me just hit pause here.
All right,
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Jesus Christ.
I should have done that 20 minutes ago.
I can't imagine how many listeners I lost.
Um,
all right,
what am I talking about?
Oh yeah.
Making the Pumpkin bread,
dude,
I got it down now you make six loaves of Pumpkin bread.
You can do that shit in his asleep.
And I found this giant fucking whisk that we got as a wedding gift.
You know,
uh,
my wife registered it,
you know,
that was registered.
All that,
that shift that you think is a guy you think is dumb.
Like,
why do we need all this?
You know,
why don't we register with the flat screen TV store?
We don't do that.
Yeah.
You registered like wix and sticks,
you know,
get a bunch of fucking candles,
glasses and plates and all of that Shit.
And uh,
then all of a sudden it arrives and you're like,
yeah,
Jesus Christ,
we've got to cut all this shit up.
And the next thing you know,
you got to stock to fucking kitchen
and you're looking at that big,
dumb,
stupid fucking whisk going,
what?
We'll look at this site,
automated it.
He'll fucking make some pancakes with a green giant with what?
What do I need?
A West is big four.
I'll tell you when you need it.
When you're making six loaves of Pumpkin bread and you standing on a fucking
chair just stirring that,
stirring that shit.
I get it,
man.
I fucking love Bacon.
It's just,
it's like controlled,
like playing in like a mud puddle.
It's like you being a little kid again and I got to tell you,
it's delicious.
And I ate a bunch of it and uh,
I'm not liking the shape I'm in right now.
I'm fucking Billy fat again right now.
It's fucking driving me nuts.
And uh,
I got to start working out again and someone told me,
Oh,
day,
what are you talking about?
You look good.
It's like,
no,
no.
I know I have a shirt on.
Most people look good when you put clothes on them.
You know,
when you,
when you're,
when you're hiding the mistakes.
And that's basically how you stay in shape.
You know,
every night before you go to bed,
you take your shirt off and you look at it,
you look at the damage that you created in the mirror and you do every sort of
band you can pass of bend to the side,
bend to the other side,
right?
Standard aside,
you know,
bend over at the waist and you just see that fucking spare tire.
Just grab a whole fucking handful of it.
Look at you.
You fucking piece of Shit,
Huh?
I don't know willpower.
That first half was bullshit.
We're going to go down a dark corner.
You get fucking psych yourself up.
You Psych yourself up and it's all about the next God damn day.
When you wake up in the morning,
it's like you're coming out of the locker room at halftime.
All right,
and what are we gonna do?
We gonna make some halftime adjustments.
Are we going to go right back to the frosted flakes and what are you gonna do?
You're gonna make some red velvet pancakes.
You tubers shit.
Huh?
Are you going to get some great nuts and have a banana?
Then I make some oatmeal.
That's what you need to do.
You got to get the fucking oatmeal.
What does that shit that I'm telling you dude?
It's,
it's,
it's uh,
I,
I used to never believe that food is a drug.
It's 100% of drug and you've got to fucking,
when you start eating badly,
you've got to force yourself to just fucking eat a salad and it just fucking
stops those cravings like dead and the track.
It's a fucking,
it's a stiff arm,
right to the sugar,
salt bullshit.
You know,
same thing with working out.
I didn't work out for like at least like 10 days and I kept sitting on the
couches.
I'm watching sports going to bill just fucking dropped the floor and just give,
you know,
Bang out a hundred pushups and I just do it to my,
I don't feel like,
Eh,
you don't cause she hasn't been eating like shit.
I mean Pumpkin bread,
I got that shit in my body and it's,
it's fucking eating away at my brain and as is is the smart part of me is going
compel,
get up,
go for a walk.
You paste the top of Shit,
right?
The pumpkin pumpkin bread's getting stronger.
It's in there.
It's going to add all that.
Say,
hey him,
sit on a couch.
Come on.
You are,
and d even working hard,
right?
So yesterday I finally got off the couch and my body's screaming
and I just forced myself.
And within five,
six of them,
you know,
you get that he stuck getting that rush that you're working out.
You know,
you stand up after what did,
banging
out a set of 25 35 or whatever,
right?
You get up and all of a sudden you feel good.
You start strutting around,
you know,
first dad,
I like you just made them nice fucking catch on.
Third Down,
saving the drive.
You dropped down and do not 35 starting to do it.
I'm gonna get fucking shredding.
I'm aware that Mark Walberg fucking underwear walking around all shredded,
right?
You start thinking shit like that just after two sets.
But if you didn't override that fucking Mcdonald's in your brain and he just sat
there,
you know what you're gonna do,
you're going to add another fucking layer of fat
and you're going to go into the bathroom at night hanging your head when you
brush your teeth because you know you don't want to look at it.
Now you've got a t shirt on,
you can see it come through your fucking tee shirt.
You can't hide that shit.
Right?
That big pile of mush clinging to your fucking rib cage.
Awful looking like a fucking,
I don't know what I get new,
certain level of shape.
I just feel like I should be tied to the risks hanging from a tree and be used
as a pin,
Yada.
Oh,
it's disgusting.
I was just thinking the fucking beat me and candy comes out of my ass cause I've
been eating so bad.
I'm sorry.
Whatever.
What do you want from me?
So now I'm back on the stick.
So,
you know,
all I did was I did a hundred pushups and uh,
I woke up today thinking about doing pull ups.
Had I not done that,
I'd be fucking out.
Dave eating pumpkin bread.
Nah,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm going to eat another slice of it.
Oh.
And I'm putting butter on it.
All right,
but you just gotta.
You know,
you just got to refuse to get past a certain point.
You have to have a fucking line in the sand line in the butter.
Will you just like,
I'm not going past this.
I'm not going past this shit.
So
you know what I'm talking about.
Trying to stay in shape,
which obviously now I can effortlessly segue into the Ebola panic.
All right?
I'm sitting there watching 60 minutes.
Okay.
And I got all these famous people telling me that they're tired of me beating
women.
All these women that I'm not beating.
All right?
I'm watching the world series on being reminded that people lose people to
cancer every day.
Which is it,
which is always nice.
You know,
when you're watching the national pastime,
take me out to the ball game.
Take me out to the crowd.
I just lost my mother to throat cancer bull.
Whoa,
whoa.
I mean,
what the,
what the fuck are you doing?
I don't want to see that during the fucking gang.
Okay.
We just have like the cancer channel,
like the disease channel.
You don't,
every once in a while I'll fucking click over there and I'll write out,
you know,
send in five bucks or whatever the fuck I gotta do.
Do you really have to interrupt?
If
am I out of my mind that I think it's unbelievably fucking
to do that to people.
What,
what are the,
what are the fuck are they going to do next?
You're going to crash some little boy's birthday party.
Happy Birthday to no more,
no more.
She felt face first into a birthday cake
lady.
He's five years old.
Hey,
just in case you haven't heard everybody,
it's not okay to hit a woman just in case you were a little confused.
Uh,
cocaine is bad for you.
Ah,
just to let you know,
a,
when somebody dies of cancer,
there's people that love them and they miss the person afterwards and it's very
painful.
Just thought we would remind you that while you're trying to watch the Kansas
city royals and the San Francisco giants,
So then you know is if all of that shit,
this is bread and circus time,
this is mouth breed of time and you're coming in here bringing up the horrors of
the world,
right?
So I'm watching a the four o'clock game and all they keep doing on CBS is they
keep hyping on 60 minutes that they're going to be talking about three or four
nurses,
three of which are guys,
right.
Which means the three ladies that were going to be nurses are now doctors,
which is far as I can tell is three out of four nurses are now men and three out
of four doctors are now women.
And this still bitching.
All right.
And don't even tell me my math is off on that cause we'll fuck where all the
female nurses,
they know where to be filed because they bitch Moan and complain to get
themselves to hold the scalp and the now what the fuck are we doing?
What?
We're walking around changing bed pans and the fucking coming on my football to
tell me not to hit you.
Uh,
you want to take a bed pan right across your back,
like wrestling with a steel chair,
taking all the doctor jobs.
You women got a lot of nerve.
Um,
anyways,
so what do they do?
They start fucking hypen.
They start hyping that they're going to talk to these four people that were near
an Ebola patient who didn't catch a bola and how fucking scared they are.
You know,
it's funny,
the people actually caught a bulla.
How many have even died?
You know,
you know what a bowl is?
A bullet is the Cincinnati bangles of diseases.
They started fucking strong.
Everybody thought they were a contender,
right?
They knocked the ice bucket challenge right off the map.
Everybody was talking about fucking als ice bucket challenge and incomes.
A Bolo,
right?
Like if it was a nightclub,
a bullet comes walking in a little hotter shoes,
a little Horia,
right?
And everybody starts looking over at that bitch,
walking into the fucking club.
And then als is over there with the ice bucket.
We went,
wait a minute,
and I'm doing the wet t shirt thing over here.
Guys don't like this anymore.
Sorry.
Als.
There's a better look and horror on the pole.
So not everybody's over here looking at this fucking a bowl of shit.
We're going to be fine,
everybody.
This is a deal.
Let's just say,
let's just say a couple hundred thousand people die of a bull,
all right?
You know we have like over 300 million people in this country,
okay?
So the way I look at it,
it's like you got a giant football team here.
A Bola takes out 200,000 people.
That's like when you make your final cuts in the preseason.
Now we got,
we were a little more streamlined,
all right?
Whose kidney would do it?
If you get a bowler,
you're weak.
You're a weak person,
okay?
You don't have the intestinal fortitude.
You don't have the mental toughness,
okay?
To fucking survive in a world of diseases,
And when you get a bullet,
why don't you have the fucking decency to not go to the fucking airport,
all right?
Just walk down the street into the woods and just bleed out by yourself like a
gentleman.
Why?
Why can't you do that?
Is,
is there a reason for that?
That's my question.
I'm going to take college here in 20 minutes.
Um,
how far into the sand might this fucking absolute horse shit?
Uh,
all right.
What have I talked about?
Oh Man.
What's it been watching this?
A little bit of hockey.
This is such a tough year to try and keep up with everything.
I've been really watching the world series though.
Um,
I'm,
I missed most of game four.
I think I did.
Uh,
I was watching something else.
I forget what,
but uh,
Jesus,
Kansas City came back,
they lost the first one for those.
You're not watching.
They came back,
they won game two and three.
They were up two games to one up two games to one.
Right.
And then they go out to s.
You know,
there are actually,
they won the first game in San Francisco and then,
uh,
I was hoping that they were going to win either one game a four or five and they
didn't,
they lost them both.
It was like the giant,
I don't know if there's a way to make a halftime adjustment,
but that's what it looks like the giants did.
I just think that they ran into some tough pitching and,
uh,
so who knows,
who knows?
But,
um,
I don't have any sort of feeling on this series.
Like I don't feel like if Casey wins game six that they're going to win game
seven.
I hope they do.
I liked the royals.
I also really like the giants too,
so I'm not being addicted.
People in San Francisco,
it's just,
you know,
I just saw the giants win 2010 2012.
Um,
and it was great to see that.
but I'd like to,
you know,
to see Casey get when,
however,
if the giants win,
um,
that's three world series in the 2000 and they would join the Boston red sox.
We want Oh four oh seven and 2013.
Um,
because basically somebody is going to be the Yankees of this,
uh,
century.
Someone's going to be the one who won the most fucking,
uh,
you know,
team of the century basically.
How many,
how many world series,
how many [inaudible],
how many world series do you think it's going to take to be the,
uh,
the team of this century?
Because now that you got 30 fucking teams,
what's crazy is if Kansas city wins this year,
the fact that it took them 29 years,
they're actually on average mathematically,
you know,
you got a one in 30 chance chance of winning now
that they would be,
uh,
that for them to win one in 29 years.
They actually came in a year early.
My math fucked up on that.
I'm sure it is.
I'm not the smartest guy out there,
especially when it comes to the fucking arithmetic there.
Um,
I'm actually thinking if you won,
if you want 12,
maybe
if you want 12th,
I would think that you'd get it at this point with 30 fucking teams that's
waiting better than one a decade.
MMM.
So like right now,
the red sox are ahead of the curve.
I can't believe I even get to say that after all the shit they went through is
they've won three,
so they're actually good through the 2000 twenties and I think we're going to
get another one before then.
MMM.
I think the Yankees are a,
I don't know.
I think that they're all,
all of those teams,
the Celtics,
the Yankees,
the Canadians,
all of those teams that one,
like fucking nine zillion titles when they was like fucking 15 teams in the
League of 10 teams in the league.
Uh,
you know,
that's over.
Like back in the day when the Yankees used to win titles.
Do you know when,
when you won your division that was winning the pennant?
They had so few teams that there wasn't another division you had to play.
Forget about two rounds of fucking baseball.
Best four out of seven to get to the final thing.
Now I'm not,
you know,
fucking with the Yankees legacy because it's the most legit thing there is
considering babe Ruth,
Lou Gehrig,
Joe Dimaggio and Mickey Mantle.
No one's ever going to have a fucking run a players like that.
Again,
you're lucky if you go back to back with two unbelievable players,
spaghetti about foreign around.
MMM.
But nobody's going to win at a clip like that again.
Like I don't see anybody ever catching the Yankees like how bad the Yankees
would have to nosedive.
And they're spending like,
you know,
200 million a year.
I think they've,
they've lowered their,
their yearly average and at this point,
but generally speaking,
they send him to spend roughly 200 million bucks a year.
If you do that year after year after year,
uh,
you know,
you're going to win a couple here,
a couple there and you're going to stay out front.
I cause I think the closest that is to them is I think the cardinals and they
got like 11,
10 or 11,
I can't remember what.
And that puts them like a good 16,
16 behind.
It's over.
No one's going to catch
them.
No one's gonna catch the,
uh,
the Canadians.
MMM.
Both of them are just too out far in front.
But then with basketball,
like I think the Lakers are going to overtake the Celtics just because of
Ah,
okay.
People would rather play in La,
like Boston and La are equally racist.
MMM.
And a lot of people don't think that just because for some reason we get all the
attention,
you know,
despite the fact that they have fucking riots out here and that police are
constantly fucking murdering people.
Um,
yeah,
I would say.
Yeah.
So then it just comes down to better weather.
Um,
and celebrity pussy,
I mean right there and you know,
yeah.
It's basically,
what do you want to,
do you want to play in the racist town with the bad weather and a,
the potato faces or do you want to come out here with the plastic surgery ass
and the great weather with the racism?
I mean,
it's a no fucking brainer.
They're going to come out here.
Um,
so
I dunno,
unless we go on some sort of a fucking run,
that's the only real race that there is.
And for those you don't keep up on it.
The south except 17 and the Lakers had 15 plus a be a championship that they
have to count as an NBA championship for some fucking reason.
I don't,
I don't understand that.
I don't understand how I've said it before.
I don't understand how to fuck.
You can win an NBA championship before the NBA exists.
It's unbelievable.
But you know,
it's La.
That's what you do.
I'm a director.
I got 16 championships.
All right.
Uh,
let's,
let's read a little bit of advertising here.
Oh,
by the way,
oh,
if I'm,
okay,
let me get this out of the way here.
If you would like to buy my,
uh,
my standup comedy album and you do not live in the continental United States,
um,
my record is available for international orders@thirdmanrecords.com.
Third man records.com t h I r d man,
records.com.
You can order it there.
And,
um,
reminders for listeners of the podcast,
the email to ask me questions is bill@themmpodcast.com.
bill@themmpodcast.com.
All right,
let's get into a,
okay,
let's get into some questions here for the week.
Um,
all right.
Okay.
Shaving in the steam room.
All right.
What do we got here?
Bill?
You like steams after my workout,
I like to take a steam.
What I find is people coming in and shaving in the steam room.
What the fuck dude?
People at just stiff fucking animals,
man.
Fucking animals.
This is sign outside.
No shaving,
but it must be for someone else.
You're a quick witted guy.
What backhanded response can I give these assholes when they come in and start
shaving?
Okay.
Am I the most negative guy ever that I took your,
you're a quick witted guy as an insult.
Hey Bill,
you're a quick witted guy.
Why don't you write me a fucking comeback?
What am I on the writing staff of your life here,
sir?
MMM.
What would you say?
I would sit there and the Steve,
you like buddy.
There's no shaving in here.
Let's disgusting.
We all have to use it.
What's wrong with you?
You fucking animal.
Oh,
look who's here.
Look who's here.
Everybody.
It's the lovely Nia making of parents for the first time in a while people
thought you dumped me.
Get over here.
I only have one microphone.
Don't touch the fucking mixer.
What are you doing?
Oh,
Jesus.
Listening to you screaming like a moron about God knows what.
What are you yelling about again?
Mia?
This,
this podcast is a,
it's an important thing.
I got to bring the energy.
I get to bring the,
I know it's literally Monday morning your leg.
Oh,
how blood and butter on it.
And he's fucking screaming about Pumpkin bread.
It's nine in the morning.
What is the matter with you?
Seriously?
And when someone calls Azzie for a,
uh,
a nice quip or something to say to somebody,
you get an attitude about it.
What's the matter with you?
I Dunno.
Look,
look how it's written.
It's written.
Tell me I'm wrong there.
Somebody was shaving in the steam room.
How gross is that?
It's disgusting.
Absolutely fucking disgusting.
They should literally just put a collar around that guy and stick him in a
fucking cage.
Take him down to the pound.
Yeah,
I mean he can either just go straight up to him.
Like you said a buddy,
there's no shaving and hear that sounds like exactly what we would say.
You would definitely say,
hey buddy,
and that really fucking tense away.
No,
I would or you could like,
you know what he should sell on then to the uh,
place and get them band or what you stand up here where we were getting reports
that you're,
you're shaving in the same room and Sarah,
well you've been warned several times about this where it has asked you to
leave.
Can I have your,
your locker room key please?
No,
the guy initially denies it.
I wasn't shaving in there.
And then the guy like gently reaches out and touches the side of his face.
Come on.
We both know.
We both know there's no way your face is going to be that smooth unless you're
shaving.
You know what the guy that you guys should do is just stand up and start peeing
on his leg and this is what you do.
You say,
yeah,
no.
You say,
sir,
there's no shaving in here.
And if he has an attitude,
then you pee on his leg and then you both get kicked out and then you make the
news.
Oh,
go,
go home.
Like that.
TMC A Matt was Shayla.
I was also going to make the show.
Let me get a tighter shirt.
The metal is metal shaving in the state room and this other guy,
he gets somebody please.
No,
no,
I haven't.
That's my TMC impression.
I hate that you watch that stupid fucking show with all those Goddamn
geeks standing around.
And I watch it on a regular basis,
but I do a,
I watch it from time to time to get caught up on the,
on the celebrity.
See,
I have never seen however long,
it seems like it's an hour long,
an hour long of nothing.
Just watching people coming out of restaurants,
you know,
hey Sean Penn,
what do you think about a boa?
And he's just like,
why?
I just had some muscles.
Oh,
cleo.
Cleo wants to be in the blog.
All right.
It was going off the rails.
It's going off the rails here.
Get down the original cock block.
Anytime we hug,
the dog comes over like I want to be a part of it.
Go lay down.
Get over there.
Get over there stupid.
Don't call the dogs.
Oh,
that dog.
I fucking love that dog.
You don't even understand.
All right.
Yeah.
You don't understand that.
Do understand the way you throw yourself on top of her and go,
oh,
glow or the loudest possible.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
You can't stop doing it.
Do it constantly throughout the day.
You do it like 10 times a day.
I'm not exaggerating.
I'm not going to defend myself.
It's like,
how do you not go over and hug your dog?
That's what I do.
I always go,
all right.
She,
she sees me coming over.
She lays down on her side and I just grabbed her and I squeezed her and I
scream,
oh yeah,
you get her.
You know,
and who takes her for a hike every fucking day?
Yeah,
you do.
But you also like literally you walk into the room and she's like up on her feet
and she's like,
Huh?
Like you,
you're giving the dog your energy,
your manic energy.
I know I'm a fucking psycho.
What do you want from me?
But you know what?
I don't shave in the steam room.
So what would I say to this guy?
I would say,
uh,
I'd be like,
buddy,
there's no shaving in here.
That's fucking,
yeah,
gross.
What's wrong?
You little stupid whiskers are going to be there on the floor.
He fucking animal,
Dude.
I sweating
God.
I swear to God,
the fucking animals that go into steam rooms.
Fucking animals.
Fucking guy
cleaning the does toenails or is dead skin off of his feet.
Just sitting there scrubbing it.
Yeah.
No,
you know something.
I only think that that's 10% of people that go into steam rooms.
I think the rest of us,
we need to speak up.
We're just sitting there silently.
They're not saying anything.
She's,
what the fuck is wrong with you dude?
It's gross.
Sitting there yelling at somebody.
You both got your dicks out and not a thick things flapping around.
Alright.
Remaining positive.
I'm a 23 year old,
recent recent college graduate who's dealing with a bit of depression,
having never dated,
finding it hard.
Did I write this?
Having never dated,
finding it hard to get a job and having no actual goal life.
I'm finding it hard to keep motivated to do anything.
I normally eat well and go to the gym,
but that's the only healthy habit I have.
I want to be enjoying my twenties but because I've accomplished nothing,
not even having formed any relationships with any girl,
it's been hard to smile and remain positive.
Do you get into these sorts of funks and what advice would you have to get out
of it?
Any advice from you or the lovely?
Nia would honestly make a major impact on my life.
No pressure.
Yeah,
body.
Jesus.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
I literally could have written that at 23 years old.
I was basically in the,
uh,
essentially the same boat.
Um,
had no fucking,
I was still living at home,
had no girlfriend.
I commuted all the way through college.
I didn't have any college friends,
never went to any of those parties or any of that type of shit.
MMM,
okay.
And I was actually flailing one on what the fuck I was gonna do with my life.
I tried sales,
I worked in warehousing,
I had a job at a dental office and none of it was making me excited about going
to work.
And I started thinking like,
Oh fuck,
am I going to be that guy?
That guy that just does a fucking job that he hates sin.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I just started every day.
I Dunno.
I'm just trying to think what I wanted.
What did I want?
And um,
don't look at it with judgment or think that something's impossible.
Like whatever you want to do to be sitting there thinking like,
oh,
I can't do that.
I could never do that.
You can,
you can.
I am an absolute moron and if I can make something happen,
you definitely can.
I,
I would.
I would say that I don't like how you laugh when I said I'm a moron.
You are a moron.
But I think you just gave really,
really perfect advice.
That's great advice.
You got to figure it out.
Yeah.
What is it that you really,
really enjoy doing?
And maybe there's a way to actually make a living at it.
Like,
Bill,
yeah,
this is what you just start doing it.
You just start fucking doing it and then eventually it turns in to your job and
all you do is just,
I think what most people do is like,
say they're thinking like,
I don't know,
pick a job that's fucking a,
you're like,
oh,
I could never do that.
I'll just keep it in entertainment.
Say you wanted to
get into like I'm broadcasting,
I guess announcing schemes and you start thinking like,
oh my God,
I want to announce NFL Games.
How the fuck do I get there?
Um,
so you start,
you know,
I would think you'd start doing high school games,
little league games.
I would do anything.
I would just,
if no one was hiring me,
I would just show up at little league games with a fucking sport coat on and set
up a table and I would just start doing it.
I would go down to pickup basketball games.
I just,
that's not creepy at all.
Just start doing,
just showing up at the little kids gave him like here I am.
I know cause now cause his pedophiles,
there's always been pedophiles.
What am I going here I am,
I'm going to watch started molesting a kid is everyone's sitting there.
I would just start doing the game.
Like it was a major league baseball game.
The parents would love it.
You could go down to like the uh,
the basketball courts.
I would just anything just to,
just to be doing it.
That's like your open.
So I'm not getting paid.
I'm learning how to do this shit and then I dunno,
start taking some classes at a broadcasting school.
You just,
every part of your day becomes announcing,
you know?
Right.
I,
when I had day jobs,
I used to sit there doing the job and I would be any,
any funny fucking idea ahead.
I would just write it down and um,
and then I would go try it out somewhere and I just kept doing it and doing it
and doing it and do it.
You just,
you just start marching towards it and you don't look at like,
well,
Hey,
I just fuck 'em I'm doing high school games.
I'll never get to the NFL.
Like most people don't get there because they want it in a week.
Dude,
they're fucking helicopters are going to fly into the fucking house around here.
That crazy.
I don't know if you guys could just hear that ship.
Um,
they uh,
yeah,
you just,
every single day you just,
I don't know,
look at this stupid ass podcast.
I just kept doing it every Monday and all of a sudden,
you know,
I got a bunch of listeners.
Okay.
Curious about cause I'm trying to,
you know,
I'm always trying to like read between the lines and he goes,
I normally eat well and go to the gym,
but that's the only quote unquote healthy habit I have.
What does that mean?
Well I don't want to start.
Why that guy?
I'm just,
I'm just curious as why that got thrown in there because I don't know if that
means that there's things that he's doing that he is not healthy because the
rest of it doesn't really,
I dunno.
I normally well and go to the gym.
That's the only healthy Abbott I have.
Like it's or it's like they only thing
habit I have.
It's just like working out and going to the gym,
but I don't have any other like things like does the healthy and quotes is a,
it concerns me a little bit while I think he's really hard on himself so he's
got to lighten up on self.
So even when he's doing something,
even when he's doing something positive,
he still puts it in quotes.
He won't give himself credit for there.
It sounds like you maybe had some negative parents who told you the world was a
lot more difficult than it is.
I would,
uh,
I'd also work on like,
just paying attention to the thoughts in your head.
That's how,
cause I was never clinically depressed,
but I was definitely,
I've had definitely bouts of depression and function,
that type of thing.
I felt like shit yesterday when I was watching the game and I did,
uh,
a hundred pushups and you know,
three sets.
Okay.
I can actually like actually dropped down.
I had a heart attack.
No,
know I did.
I this set of three and I got to a hundred,
105 actually sets it 30 flag.
Right?
You folks.
Um,
no,
but I immediately felt better.
Right?
I immediately felt better.
So,
and also you're 23 years old,
you have a long,
long time to figure out what it is that you want to do for the rest of your
life.
You know what I mean?
And it's probably going to change several times.
So maybe you just graduated college and you're like,
oh,
I majored in business.
I don't want to get into business.
I really want to be a veterinarian,
something like that.
And I think that bill's right.
You should,
when I want to do it,
I would immediately start picking up roadkill off of the side of the road and
I'd try to see if I could bring it back to life.
Reviving it,
reviving that a dead cat on the freeway.
No,
no.
Just,
yeah,
you're fine.
You're 23 you got your whole life ahead of you.
You don't,
it can be worse.
Do.
You could be in a relationship and you fucking knocked her up and now you're
tied to her for the rest of your fucking life.
And then you've got to go get a job.
It's someplace you want to work at.
So the fact that you don't have anything going on in your life is fucking
awesome.
There's nothing holding you back.
You can just now you can.
You actually get to decide.
You know what I mean?
People would want to be in your fucking position.
23 no girlfriend,
you know,
no fucking mortgage,
no bullshit,
none of that stuff.
It's just you still fucking,
you know,
figuring out what you want to do and go after it and uh,
tell that negative thought and you had to go fuck yourself.
There you go.
That was like a doctor Phil episode.
That solves all your problems.
Well we come back.
I yell at more men.
Yeah,
just work on yourself.
The wrestle.
The rest will come together.
Don't worry about the girl part yet.
Just get,
get your own shit together.
I already said that.
Why did you feel like you get,
you keep trying.
Keep trying.
You keep trying to say,
you could try and be the person who says the last thing.
This is my podcast.
I wrap it up.
I wrapped it in me to come in here.
You wanted me to come in here?
I did.
So stop giving me shit.
You the next question.
All right.
Artificial intelligence.
Also known as Bill Burr.
Oh Jesus.
Artificial intelligence.
And it's,
as long as there's intelligence in there,
I'll take it.
And its impact on humanity.
Dill.
Dear Bilbo Baggins,
what are your thoughts on Tesla founder Elon Musk?
Warnings on artificial intelligence?
I just love the fact that you think that I actually read it,
he said that through recursive self improvement,
simple tasks like preventing spam could lead to an AI determining humans are the
problem.
It's just like a Scifi script and,
okay.
Yeah I got that.
I'm,
I'm totally interested but I don't know what's going on here.
Recursive self improvement means it could reason with itself.
Oh this is a uh,
like when you make it
pure that like has emotions like a human being.
No,
it's like,
like he's talking about,
we're trying to get rid of the spam and email and stuff,
but whatever program is like,
wait,
there's a human being behind the spam.
There's a,
there's a human being behind the Nigerian prince scheme or the,
Oh my God friend.
I'm trapped in Denmark and I've had my passport and all my money like taken from
me and
I don't think that is,
I think he's talking to AI.
Simple tasks like preventing spam could lead to AI.
Artificial intelligence is a computer.
Yeah.
The robot determining humans are the problem.
Okay.
So how is there a guy in Nigeria recursive self improvement?
It's realizing that human beings are behind the spam in your email.
Like there's someone,
oh I see what you mean.
I see what you're saying.
Okay.
Sorry about that.
Um,
that's going to be a long one.
Recursive self improvement means it could reason with itself and incrementally
improved to overcome obstacles that prevent it from fulfilling its objectives.
I listened to previous podcasts and you've mentioned you think there would be a
backdoor built into any AI machine robots by the powers that be,
however,
using the recursive self improvement that Alon mentioned in AI could eventually
reason with itself that a backdoor preventing it from fulfilling its mandate
must be ignored or overcome.
Elon Musk is very intelligent,
having found founded paypal space x and Tesla as well as playing a key role in
solar city.
So I don't think his concerns should be taken lightly.
Here's a book that delves into the subject in more detail because I know you're
a deep thinker.
See what I'm saying?
They're all giving me shit.
Oh that's bloody.
Our final invention,
artificial intelligence and the end of the human error.
Thanks for your,
uh,
for your fucking opinion.
Um,
is this some like sort of like 1984 type shit like you know,
1984 was humans on humans.
Ah,
okay.
We'll see there.
It's just,
that's already going on.
That's already going on where someone who was our ally yesterday is now the
enemy and then the enemy is now the ally and vice versa and all that type of
show.
This is basically like the machines are getting so smart that they're going to
eventually like take over.
Yeah.
Here's the thing about machines and yet they don't have legs.
Robots might,
maybe that's his whole point.
Like the robots,
the robots I'm afraid of,
but just like a computer,
right.
It's like you don't have legs and you have an ability,
an umbilical cord plugged into that fucking wall over there and I,
we'll snip that fucker and I will dump water on you.
And that's the end of use water on you.
Yeah.
Go dump water on your computer.
See what happened.
Aren't they talking about making robots?
That'll be able to like surpass all of that shit and that's the scary part about
it.
It's like you don't want to give them too much intelligence because like he was
saying,
they'll learn that like,
hey wait,
I've got this whole back door thing and fuck that back door.
Well cause they're going to evolve beyond that.
Here's the thing,
what people don't understand her.
Did you ever see that movie her with Hakim?
Phoenix,
there was too much red.
I was just too much red.
He was the only one really that word red.
But anyway,
go on.
Anyways,
this is what I feel people are actually acting like this.
Just some nerdy scientists,
angling communities.
How many patients,
anytime I can bullshit it isn't it's rich people and rich people at the top want
to phase out us.
The sick of us,
like we are an inconvenience to them
with our complaints and our needs.
They want us to shut the fuck up.
They want us to all do.
We making fucking slippers for them for fucking 50 cents a month.
They want to have all the cars they want.
Like it's like I went to when I went to the farmer's market yesterday,
right to add to my feminine weekend of Pumpkin bread and driving a Prius that
speaking of which you need to store your strawberry is more correctly cause
they're just sitting out on the counter and they're going to go bad.
You know why?
You know I left them up there because strawberries out on the counter because
they're not organic.
I went to a farmer's market and they actually just have regular,
you have to ask them is this organic?
And then will be like,
oh you know we're forming is the blue book.
They can't even handle 200 people.
The grocery stores can handle 200 fucking people walking into a parking lot.
The by some God they mix.
They even have to get that money.
Like they just stay,
don't they?
They want,
they want it.
All the people at the top.
So can I have those tremors if you're not going to eat them.
Did you hear?
Did you hear that back and forth?
This is why we deserve to get fucking taken over right here because you can't
keep people on.
Do you just give a fuck about the strawberries?
I'm talking about the overall picture.
I don't care if the strawberries are organic or not my cause right now I'm just,
I like strawberries so I'm trying to stay on topic with this.
Say can you come near the mic please?
So basically what is this person asking you?
So he's asking me if I'm worried about artificial intelligence.
I actually think that there's human beings behind it and it's going to play out
like the classic like Frankenstein where you build it and then it comes back and
kicks the shit how you,
but like I think you know a lot of people looking at us like,
like human beings as a collective.
What are we doing?
We aren't doing anything.
You're expendable.
I'm expendable.
We're an annoyance to them.
What the reason why we're still here is because we pay taxes,
we pay interest.
They got their foot on the back of our fucking neck and we're helping to buy
some more fucking gold coins for them every single month.
But eventually,
but the,
but the thing,
the,
the big flaw with human beings is that we complain and we pay attention and we
go,
hey,
that isn't fair.
And I think super rich people are sick of it and it'd be great.
Wouldn't it be great if we could somehow get them to just work,
not bitch and not have to pay him at all?
What is the solution?
Let's make some fucking robots.
Yeah.
But then you know,
the robots would be great,
but then who are we going to fucking pull over to the side of the road and have
him suck our dicks and our back of our limos?
Well,
we got to make a more lifelike.
So they're going to try to make these lifelike robots that will do whatever the
fuck they want and suck their dicks and work out in the fields and all that
fucking shit.
But that eventually they're going to get overrun.
So you are concerned about artificial intelligence then?
No,
I'm not concerned about it because there's nothing to stop it.
I just was talking to you about it.
And your main focus is the strawberries right there.
That little microcosm of that fucking conversation is why I
tapped out a conspiracy theory.
I will not talk.
I'll,
I mean,
I'll just,
I'll do it on this podcast because I don't have list to somebody else.
Um,
either sand dad fucking bullshit or this or that or that or here's my even crazy
theory because I'm nuts.
Everybody's fucking nuts.
Uh,
everything has,
I think,
I believe everything has a beginning,
a middle and an end.
And a human beings are no different and uh,
you know,
whatever,
I'm going to die anyway.
So what the fuck do I care about?
Rich people being annoyed by non rich people.
I was just reading something online that was talking about a dear prudence,
you know,
like an advice column over the weekend or something.
And there was a rich person that was saying,
you know,
I live in a very wealthy community and um,
there are billionaires and stuff around us for the most part,
like the street where I live is his doctors and lawyers and things.
Anyway,
we just noticed that every Halloween there are all these people from the poor
neighborhoods that come in and like,
you know,
trick or treat and asked for candy and I just really feel like we're already
doing so much,
you know,
and paying so many taxes for this,
that and the other like does Halloween now has to become a social service.
And basically the advice gave her was like wow,
like you are an asshole.
Like it's Halloween,
it's kids in candy.
Like are you really trying to make a bigger statement about society or over
Halloween?
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You canceled Halloween at our house.
Not because of any sort of like class issue.
I canceled Halloween because people were coming over here.
That's and like fucking morons.
I don't want 40 year old people to standing there dead eyed looking at me like,
what's up with the candy or high school kids who isn't?
Isn't that what this guy's saying it in a way and have the decency.
All right,
well then let's take the age of the people.
I had been high schools,
kids who don't even have the decency to come in a fucking costume who don't even
have the decency to say trick or treat.
They stand there staring at you.
You would get an applause break and this guy's gated community right now,
but it's like coming to Kaiser,
you know like women of color,
but that's what makes sense
here and be like fucking weird about it.
I don't care if whoever,
any kid that comes into the neighborhood from wherever they are,
Halloween is awesome in that way because it's cute fun kids.
They're excited about going out there with their parents.
Their parents are like say thank you.
Say it like it's a lovely thing.
Give Out Candy to eight o'clock at night and then you turn the light out.
That's the thing.
I just the,
the kids that come with no costumes and it's like I'm afraid they're going to
egg the house.
So I feel like I have to give them candy.
Like it's bullshit.
It's annoying.
I just want people to,
to reciprocate the,
the spirit of Halloween.
Okay.
If that's your question handing out candy,
I need a little something from you too.
Can you imagine?
You're so broke that you look forward to Halloween so you can fucking walk up
and try to get a candy bar from another adult dealer has helped fucking the
moralizing that we're get.
We're getting off track.
We're getting off track here,
but there's also freeloaders out there too.
But this,
this the thing,
this is the thing,
meaning is what that guy you saying is how a lot of rich people view people who
aren't rich.
We,
uh,
we should be privileged that we're in their
presence.
Yeah.
Like that type of guy,
that type of guy.
Do you think that that type of guy would give a shit if the rest of the world
got phased out and was replaced by robots that would work for him?
Would never go on strike and we're so lifelike that he could fuck them and it
would feel like he was with the person.
I mean that's their idea of utopia because they're fucking sociopath.
Not all of them,
but generally speaking,
there's sociopath's is at the beginning of most,
yes,
I find novels and it's like the convenience evidence.
Great.
And then the robots eventually take over.
Yeah.
Because they're smarter than us and they've somehow been able to evolve beyond
our program,
which is kind of like what her was about a little bit.
And then,
yeah.
And then basically what happens is,
is then they forget that like they don't not,
oh,
uh,
well actually a Scifi movie,
what would happened was there'd be a few humans that they allow to live and then
we work for them.
It's basically the planet of the apes fucking template over and over and over
again.
And then we'd come back and either Mark Walberg Morris Chestnut or one of those
fucking guys would be,
um,
is that really his name?
Yes,
it is.
And that sounds like the name of a cat or is Jeff?
Yeah,
it does like somebody who like lives with cats and not people and then all of a
sudden just like it gives them like real names that over there that now that's
Maura's trash,
not strapping honking chocolate piece of gorgeousness that's in movies.
You've never said that about me.
All right.
Uh,
advice.
Okay.
It sound like I you show on harsh.
I sound like I Iisha on archer.
Nope.
Is um,
advice.
Hey Bill,
fellow red head here and needed some advice.
Gigi,
age,
another freckle face here.
I'm 21 years old and after two years of college I decided to drop out because I
didn't,
I simply didn't see a future that would make me happy.
Smart move.
You need to regroup,
figure out what you want.
I know I may have burned a bridge here and made an irrational decision,
but I really couldn't take any more of it since I felt like I was wasting my
time and effort and my dad's harder and money since he paid for the tuition.
My parents unexpectedly ecstatic,
but they are not furious either.
I have a job and all that stuff and I've been playing guitar for nearly four
years now,
so I'm not bad,
but not nearly as good as I want to be considering I like metal and crap like
that.
I'd really appreciate some advice on whether or not I made a terrible decision
because part of me said I did another set.
I didn't,
uh,
should I simply be more open about my future,
I should.
I pursue my dream of being a musician even though that's extremely a far off.
I think he meant to say far off and unrealistic.
Deep down,
I feel like I'll figure something out because I always have pass.
Wow.
When something big comes up and whatnot.
Thanks to advance really like your work and your podcast,
you cheer me up with your jokes when life gets
all right.
Yeah.
Dude,
why are you going to music school?
You're 21,
you dropped out of college.
Maybe because,
uh,
it just wasn't,
they didn't offer the kind of curriculum you were into.
So you said,
hang on a second.
I've been playing guitar for nearly four years now,
so I'm not bad,
but nearly as good as I want to be considering I like metal and crap like that.
Why don't,
why don't we sort of take this back to the first advice that you gave?
Why don't you find like telling me what to do?
Why don't you shut up?
You look gorgeous this morning,
by the way.
See how you do that people.
Um,
anyways,
I meant it.
I meant to go to law school music programs so you can get better and
play guitar.
Keep playing guitar every second.
It's like the first advice you can give.
Here's the big,
there's a big thing in this email.
I ride my ra,
my impression of red metal.
Um,
this is why school is so fucked up.
This guy is literally ignoring his heart,
staying in school cause he's following the fucking heard.
This guy wants to play guitar.
Dude,
let me ask you this.
How happy are you when you're playing guitar,
when you're doing other activities?
Are you thinking,
I wish I was playing guitar?
That that's what you supposed to be doing on whatever level.
And if you think you're not good enough,
you've been playing guitar for four years.
You can be a rhythm guitarist in a band.
How cool is Malcolm Young?
He wrote all those fucking rifts for ACD to poor guy's got them sick now,
man.
Sucks.
Um,
but anyways,
like uh,
that's what you do.
Join a fucking band.
Just join a band going down on a music store.
They always have those fucking things.
A little,
a little,
we were looking for a rhythm guitar or something for this.
Yeah,
the little fly.
Just do that and just make your whole life about music.
Give Guitar lessons.
Just your whole fucking life becomes music.
And then eventually you're going to be,
you're going to be in the music world.
You might end up,
uh,
who knows,
being a producer for albums,
you might end up being an abandoned,
makes it,
you might end up managing bay.
You're going to be in the music business.
You're going to be around music,
which is what you love.
Okay.
I think there's a reason that you did it.
I think the the reason why you thinking,
oh,
maybe I shouldn't have done that is because 99% of your friends are all,
you know,
I got two more years of college and I majored in this and I'm going to go out in
the job world and we get married,
have two and a half kids,
blah,
which is fucking fine if that's what you want to do,
but you do not want to do this.
You want to play guitar,
so you made a great decision.
Congratulations.
And the balls at that took to fucking walk away from college,
didn't have the balls to do that.
I felt like I had to finish.
I've got to get a degree,
I got to get a degree and a,
I should have just went right down to a comedy club.
I knew from the time I was 14 years old that I wanted to be a standup comic and
it took me until I was 24 to finally get the balls up to do it.
So you're way ahead of the game,
you're going to be fine.
All right.
And I've got to go to work here.
So that's,
that's going to be in here for the podcast.
Thank you everybody for listening.
Thank you to the lovely Nia for dropping in.
You're welcome.
The next time I'm coming,
come on here though.
We need to talk about some of the stuff I heard you screaming about earlier.
About what?
Something about women and something ignorant that you say,
which is,
I guess it's a fuck show.
What did I say?
They said a bedpan smashed across.
Okay.
You think that's just,
it's a wrestling reference.
Well,
you talking about Ebola or something like that too.
I don't know what it was or something like that.
Something along those lines.
Does.
Speaking of that ignorance,
I gotta,
I gotta read some advertising.
Um,
I thought I heard you're doing that.
Are there,
well,
I've got one more left.
Hulu plus everybody.
You've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch your shows on your
schedule.
Who will plus has all of your favorite shows like cosmos,
a space odyssey,
Bob's Burgers or undateable starring crystally the beast.
I went on tour with them this,
this,
this year,
uh,
fees on it.
It's going to be hilarious and watch every episode of shows like South Park,
the Cosby show or doctor who Hulu plus works on your computer,
your smart phone,
your smart TV,
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox.
Pretty much any streaming device you already own.
You should be blocking off a day,
just a bench.
That's a little extreme with Hulu plus you're in total control.
Stream these and thousands more as much as you want whenever you want.
Also get exclusive access to stream the criterion collection,
movies and Hulu plus has all of them all movies and kid shows our ad free to a
formerly seven 99 a month.
Get your shows anytime,
anywhere,
but right now I'm offering my listeners a two week free trial.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's a whole extra week for free.
Please make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you get an extended free trial.
And so they know that we sent you a,
it helps us keep the lights on and gives you a better deal.
One more time for that extended free trial.
Hulu plus.com/.
Bill.
That's it.
And look at Clio over there.
You think I'm not gonna go hug her.
All right,
that's it.
I'll talk to you next week.
Go Fuck Yourself.